hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in part one of
the spoke zarathustra Friedrich
Nietzsche is going to discuss virtue to
condemn German and the virtues in the
plural there's two main sections in
which there are sustained discussions on
this one is in of joys and passions and
in that Nietzsche is providing you his
own views and of course the mouths of
Zarathustra on virtues and and whether
there's something good to have and how
they ought to be understood and how they
ought to be managed and then in the on
the chairs of virtue he is setting out a
fairly representative and in his view
mistaken conception of the nature of
virtue and we could talk here about
false virtues or a false conception of
virtue and a truer or right conception
of virtue so we should look first at
this this section of the chairs of
virtue here Zarathustra is going along
with the young men remember Zarathustra
is around thirty years old at this time
so he's not a youth but he's not
middle-aged yet he hears a wise man
praised who is said to discourse well on
two topics virtue
also sleep so he's giving people advice
about sleep and what you need to do in
order to have good deep fulfilling sleep
and it turns out that virtue plays an
important role in this so the wise man
says honor to sleep and modesty before
it this is the first thing avoid all who
sleep badly and awake at night sleeping
is no mean art you know you have to do
things in order to be able to sleep well
and he comes up with what he calls his
40 thoughts which is kind of interesting
to explore he says you must overcome
yourself ten times a day that causes a
fine weariness and is opium to the soul
so when you want to eat more than you
should
okay overcome yourself and that would be
a virtue that would be temperance right
when you get angry with somebody and you
don't retaliate but you hold yourself
back okay that would be overcoming
yourself and we could go on and on and
on so ten times a day you're supposed to
do that
ten times you must be reconciled to
yourself again overcoming as bitterness
the unreconciled man sleeps badly you
must discover ten truths a day otherwise
you will seek truth in the night your
soul will be hungry so we could talk
about the intellectual virtues in that
case or you know curiosity and then he
says you must laugh and be cheerful ten
times a day or your stomach will disturb
you in the night and then he says if you
know it but if you want to sleep well
you must have all of the virtues and
this is actually a big issue in the
field that we call virtue ethics can a
person just have one virtue or do you
really need to have all of the virtues
are the virtues truly separate from each
other or are they brought together in a
kind of harmony with each other if
they're properly understood this is
something that Plato Aristotle the
Stoics the Epicureans all these people
all the way down to the present have
have thought about in terms of the
virtues this guy is saying you need to
have all of the virtues or you're not
going to sleep well at night
it gives us
apples shall I bear false witness shall
I commit adultery shall I covet my
neighbor's maidservant none of this
would be consistent with good sleep and
you might say well I'm not hearing the
virtues being discussed there well you
know temperance as opposed to lust right
or justice as opposed to greediness or
pick whatever you want if you don't have
the virtues this goes well you're not
going to sleep well because you're gonna
do things that you shouldn't do or
you're gonna desire to do things that
you you shouldn't do and then you're not
going to sleep and then he he goes on
and he says something really quite
interesting even when one has all the
virtues there's still one other thing to
remember to send even these virtues to
sleep at the proper time so sleep takes
priority over the virtues the virtues
are there to serve sleep restfulness
you know happiness whatever it is that
we're considering it to be the the
central goal why would your virtues have
to be put to sleep
well because otherwise he recognizes
this there's a tendency for virtues
themselves to as motives of the human
being to go a bit too far to fall into
conflict with each other
he says that they may not quarrel
amongst themselves the pretty little
women and over you unhappy man and so
the idea is like the virtues are sort of
like jealous
you know people flirting with you or
wanting to be in a relationship with you
and he's just pulling you one way
against the other and you're not going
to really be happy if they're fighting
with each other so if you really want to
have a good life only goes so far with
the virtues just enough to make yourself
feel good to feel all right about
yourself so you can have some good sleep
and zarathustra here's all of this and
he says well his wisdom is stay awake in
order to sleep well and truly if life
had no sense and I had to choose non
census this would be the most desirable
for me - it's clear what people were
once seeking above all when they sought
the teacher
virtue the philosophers the sages they
saw it could sleep and opium virtues to
bring it about so these people don't
actually have some idea of the meaning
of life and they don't really have a
what we called noble conception of the
virtues so what does nietzsche offer in
place of this to this we need to turn to
the section which is called of joys and
passions and there's three main things
three main discussions in there that are
important to go over the first is he
says if you have a virtue and it is your
own virtue it belongs to you then you
have it in common with no one combines
them there's no there's no commonality
there's no universality and he cautions
us against naming it now why don't we
want to name it I mean this is an
instinct in human beings we we always
want to be able to say what is it that
I'm feeling what is it that I'm thinking
what is it I'm experiencing the the
naming of something in some respects is
liberabit Liberatore or it's it's
powerful right feels good to be able to
finally say oh that feeling of coziness
that's created by having you know
comforters and candles oh that's you
know who be right and in Danish or that
that wish to hurt somebody and see them
fail or you know be in pain for for you
know not for the sake of anything else
but just because of that
schadenfreude oh right when we have a
word we like it but that's dangerous
when it's our own virtue why he says now
you have its name in common with the
people and you've become of the people
and the herd with your virtue so when
you're able to figure out what it is
that you actually exhibit you're like
courage well your courage is just like
the other person's courage or the other
person's courage or the other person's
courage and eventually it doesn't mean
quite so much to you it's no longer your
so he says you would be better saying
unutterable a nameless does that which
torments and delights my soul and is
also the hunger of my belly when you
have a genuine virtue when you're not
just going through the motions it
becomes part of you it expresses part of
you and it moves you it drives you to do
things in your own way that other people
aren't doing it sets you apart so he
says let your virtue be to exalted for
the familiarity of names if you have to
speak of it don't be ashamed to stammer
thus say this is my good this I love
just thus do I like it only thus do I
wish the good make it your own
make it belong to you says I don't want
it as a law of God I don't want it as a
human statute let it be no signpost to
super-earths and paradises i love an
earthly virtue he says there's little
prudence Klug hight cleverness in it and
least of all common wisdom or reason so
this is a very different conception of
virtue typically when we're thinking
about virtue ethics we say ah you know
we all start out kind of messed up and
then we look to people that we think are
virtuous and we say I'm gonna be like
that person over there and you know if I
if I make some progress towards them
like towards Socrates or epictetus or
Aristotle or whoever then I'm gonna be a
good person we identify ourselves with
somebody else the traits that they have
Nietzsche is saying we should do
something different instead we should
says this bird has built its nest
beneath my roof therefore I love and
cherish it now it sits there upon its
golden eggs so there's a contingency to
it not all of us are made or born or
generated to have the same virtue or set
of virtues as everyone else and so
that's
one key idea another key idea is that
the virtues themselves rather than being
ways that we sort of manage our passions
and actions are actually arising out of
our passions he says they grow out of
our light in shopton is the the German
expression for it the things that we
suffer the things that we are gripped by
the things that move us right and so we
have these passions and early on we view
them as evil he says but now you have
only your virtues they grew out from
your passions you laid your highest aim
or goal zeal in those passions you took
them on and you said wow you know I'm
kind of a lustful person I'm kind of a
greedy person I'm kind of a driven for
status person I'm you know this and this
I'm going to say okay that that's who I
am that's what's driving me I'm going to
embrace that and then the embracing of
it rather than denying it repressing it
curbing it they're allowed to become
transformed he doesn't say how this
happens precisely but we could imagine a
process where you like look at it you're
like well I am a revenge seeker I'll do
it in this case but not in this case and
all be the one to decide how that
passion gets framed how how that happens
so he says your passions have become
virtues all your Devils have become
angels you had fierce dogs in your
cellar but they changed into birds and
sweet singers from your poison you
brewed your balls from something that
you can use as an ointment to cure right
you milked your call a flick ssin now
you drink the sweet milk and he says
henceforth nothing evil shall come out
of you unless it be the evil that comes
from the conflict of your virtues so now
we get the third key idea first one keep
your mouth shut about your virtues don't
share them with everybody else the
second they grow out of our passions the
third is that we're going to have
conflicts between our virtues unlike the
you know teacher of
ooh who says Oh make sure they don't
conflict with each other or the
philosophers who say well if it's a true
virtue it's not going to conflict with
anything else Nietzsche says multiple
virtues are going to lead to conflict -
contradiction - strife between them
inside of you and that's not going to
always feel good because you're in the
battleground you are the one who's being
pulled and driven in different places so
he goes on he says to have many virtues
is to be distinguished but it's a hard
fate you're almost better off just
having one virtue rather than a whole
bunch of them because that one virtue
it's not going to conflict with the
other virtues he says many a man has
gone into the desert and killed himself
because he was tired of being a battle
and a battleground of virtues then he
asks our war in battle evil this evil is
necessary what's necessary about it
Envy mistrust calumny among your virtues
is necessary let's consider the cardinal
virtues temperance courage wisdom and
justice if Nietzsche is correct these
will go to war against each other and
then in what sense well they're gonna
Envy each other's places they're gonna
say bad things about each other it's not
gonna be one nice harmony within oneself
why because each of your virtues is part
of you it's part of what he laters we're
going to call your will to power it's a
will that strives to dominate the others
he says each of your virtues desires the
highest place it wants your entire
spirit your entire mind that your spirit
may be its Herald it wants to take you
over and make you its own and use you to
announce itself it wants your entire
strength in what in anger Zarn hate Haas
and love liebe he tells you that every
virtue is jealous of the others and
jealousy is a terrible thing and that
even the virtues can be destroyed
through this jealousy
the virtues can not only war against
each other and make you miserable as a
result the virtues can even turn upon
themselves in that jealousy within you
so being good being noble doesn't solve
all your problems and as a matter of
fact raising your virtues to the highest
extent according to Nietzsche if they're
genuine virtues may not always make you
happy and calm and peaceful it may
actually make your life much more
complicated
should you have virtues then Nietzsche
thinks that you ought to you ought to
take your passions transform them into
virtues but realize that if you're being
realistic about this they are going to
go to war with each other and you have
to carefully manage not just your your
you know outside things by use of the
virtues so managing your consumption of
food or intoxicants or sexual pleasures
by by use of temperance you have to make
sure that that temperance doesn't get
out of bounds and start overwhelming
your courage or your wisdom or your
justice or your magnanimity or this
virtue or that virtue or something else
that it doesn't dominate your entire
being this is a very interesting an
unconventional view of the virtues that
nietzsche is articulating here
you